s'il te plaît
poulet
regarde Alessandra pas tes chaussures tu
es sa poupée car elle est méchante moi c'est
comme ça que tu dis ce parc le moment de la création de l'amour
oh tellement d'un fan Chula Oh Dolce V so Oh
belle fille
oh doux visage à Paradiso a sogno  ke
yuva race impératrice Anya je te vois dans un
rêve je rêverai pour toujours tu as
été amoureux oui ouais et comment as-tu montré à
tes gerdes je lui ai acheté une torche le
fleuriste a été abattu c'était une voiture rechargeable
Alessandra est une belle fille
non oui  regarde avec tes yeux tu sais
elle est très jolie
je vais y aller Eduardo Saudi LOUIE LOUIE montant
o album dépêche toi
pono il va bien Benny tu as deux semaines
avant le récital deux semaines pour nous faire
croire que tu es plus amoureux
que deux personnes n'en ont jamais  été amoureux
ne rêver que l'un de l'autre ne penser à
rien ni à personne d'autre Alaura à nouveau